saturday night live revealed that they
actually paid
their audience members to be there last
saturday for the season premiere they
did treat them like staff because they
had to follow such strict coveted
protocol
and get tested before coming into studio
eight h now this week bill bohr
bill burr will be hosting and morgan
wallin is the musical guest and morgan
clearly isn't quarantining before going
into the s bubble for a few days yeah so
morgan posted this photo himself
on instagram on saturday at the alabama
versus texas football game no that's
okay you just hang in with a buddy
but yeah then take a look at these
videos
that fans captured over the weekend
of morgan at various bars so he
definitely didn't know these people
because they were taking photos with him
and everything like that
no one was social distancing no one was
wearing masks you can even see he even
makes out
with a couple girls so it's definitely
raised a lot of eyebrows yeah he's
bringing it with a girl there
oh
what in god jesus in shock
ah honey i thought he was taking
pictures with fans i was like well it's
hard no to a fan i guess
this young man is making out with
everybody you just trying to get the
covet what's wrong with you
yeah read the rest of your script first
before
it is absolutely
yeah so he's probably going to the
bubble either today or tomorrow he'll be
tested
but it could be like he's not showing
symptoms yet like do you think
snl should ask their hosts and
performers to quarantine
before their appearance roz yes
yes yes yes the amount
of like the amount of problem solving
that everybody
in that production has had to go through
just to make sure
that it's safe and the show is still on
the air you can't allow
like an alien to walk in and just start
infecting everybody
and snl is one of those shows where it's
so different it's so unique to every
other
production that's out there like a ryan
and kelly that we're looking at earlier
or any of the other shows
where you can sort of contain people and
you know where they are where
they have to have a different musical
guest every week that comes with their
own band
and their own people and they have a
different host coming in every week
that's going to come with their own
people so every single week they have
crews of people that have nothing to do
with anybody
in there and they can't be monitored and
i understand going to bar i'm with you
keisha i understand going to bars you
take a couple pictures with a fan
but doing shots and making out with
strangers is first of all
it's not that's not the safest thing to
do like without kovit
right but now you're doing it now you're
doing it during covid
you know on a week where you've got to
go to new york and do saturday night
live like
they for me i would cancel them that's
just me i would cancel
i would cancel them i would postpone
them
yeah and you know what so two things one
i know et canada reached out to both
snl and morgan for comment so that's one
part of this but second
maybe plot twist maybe morgan was like
you know what
i'm going to catch this coved and
they're going to test me and i won't
have to work
maybe that seems like the only possible
explanation
exactly what he's thinking it is morgan
is in this situation where he is who he
is
a week before hitting snl and you're in
a bar you're doing shot and he looked at
that young lady
and then he thought about it for a
second and just said worth it
right shelters definitely should be
canceled especially they are planning on
sticking their tongue
down random throats zanara says those
those are the kind of actions or why we
have these numbers that kerry says i
grew through roswell she's definitely
quarantined
yeah somalia says when you go from bar
to bars you should expect that that it's
going to get filmed
yes this is i don't know him so snl
cancels them that'll be fine
here's my thing like one i'm 99 percent
sure that
artists don't get paid to appear on us
it's a huge opportunity
but i know like people that i know that
are actors that
do just background work they're actually
paid to quarantine like whatever it is i
don't know if it's a full two weeks but
they actually are actually
paid for the days leading up because
basically they're locking you in that
you can't work anywhere you can't go
anywhere
so they get paid for those days so would
it have to be a situation that
you know you i don't know have to give
performers money if you're going to say
you need to quarantine for two weeks
you can do any other gigs for two weeks
before snl is does that become a
situation where you think
they have to pay them no no
because that's what snl snl is the
biggest stage
you know one of the biggest stages that
you can that you can perform on
especially i mean you go from
you know we got no pictures of meg the
stallion last week
whooping it up and bars making out with
vendoms before her appearance
i'm not saying that didn't happen but
you didn't but you didn't see it you
weren't so brazen about it
uh this i truly i truly think that this
kind of thing is a liability
and it's exactly this and i know we're
sitting here goofing on it and
everything else
but this is exactly the kind of thing
that could get snl
shut down for the next two months
absolutely yeah absolutely
true and you know what kudos to snl
for like staying locked they could very
easily
have filmed a lot of this stuff
pre-filmed it
compiled it and just dropped it they
didn't have to make it live they could
have just
removed that element because of kovit
they wanted to keep the integrity of
their show and i think that all the cast
and crew and performers
should keep the integrity of the show
and that calls for you stay yes
yeah wait for the after party